hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren hier sieht schon juli wird dabei
und juli wenn heute horror spiel spielen
wären bereits videos gemacht in denen
juli zum ersten mal minecraft gespielt
hat so juliane stellt seinen albert
laufen das hat nicht so gut funktioniert
aber dann haben wir auch ein video
gemacht und vorne gespielt hat das war
auf jeden fall auch sehr gut deswegen
haben wir zwei uns heute gedacht dass
wir es länder die hier schon so einen
standard horrorspiel auf meinem kanal
alles klar
ich habe ich klicke jetzt einfach mal
auf start game und werde euch dabei so
ein bisschen eines länder erklären sie
das ganze spiel und ich kennen solltet
im juli wird er allgemein nicht so viel
reden in dem video bei die sich mehr auf
socken konzentrieren wird
ist schon gespannt ihr seht schon hier
kollektor pages juli
du kannst die rechte hand an dem
auspacken oder kann sich umgucken und
mit der linken hand an wsd damit kannst
du laufen darf man die klasse jura
laufen
es geht darum dass wir uns in einem wald
befinden wir sind einwanderer und wir
müssen acht seiten eines buches finden
und die sind an den ball nicht im himmel
versteckt sind an den bäumen hier
irgendwo genau da auf augenhöhe sind die
bäume die auf jeden fall ist es nun los
aufgabe dieser acht seiten zu finden und
je mehr seiten du hast lässt erscheint
ist es ist dass länder mann auftaucht
dann will ich keine
ja aber
du musst seiten finden lauf einfach mal
irgendwie so ein bisschen rum guckte ich
mal ein bisschen um genau damit läuft
schneller
das kann ich gar nicht ja aber wenn du
ihn siehst dann kannst du schnell
weglaufen also zu beginn ist das spiel
wirklich noch relativ g wieso du bist
jetzt einfach nur stell dir vor du bist
dann im wald und hast ein buch aussehen
und baum geheftet und muss wieder für
beste spielprinzip aller zeiten ziemlich
langweilig
ja bisher ist die taktik von jule dass
sie gegen bäume läuft läuft's halt auch
die ganze zeit am rand der map hierher
links steht die ganze zeit der frauen
hat es doch ein bisschen die mitte zu
laufen da links da sind autos die sie da
mal hin also der wald besteht nicht nur
aus bäumen sondern auch aus verlassenen
autos und wo ihnen dafür seite 1
[Applaus]
die sache ist jude das müssen wir die
vielleicht sagen dass länder man kann
nicht vor dir auftauchen
ja der kann allerhöchstens wenn du dich
jetzt mal umdreht oder so dass er dann
hinter dir steht nicht antreten wenn ihr
einfach vor dass du weiterhin deine
seiten sammeln muss und du bist einfach
nur einwanderer im wald dieser ist die
hand gottes du so schön die ganze sein
bruder hätten stand der hast du nicht
gesehen also jetzt geht es ja noch
relativ weit weg dann kann nicht vor dem
auftauchen jude
ja weil er nicht will dass dem die
saiten abzieht
heute wenn dieser bildschirm so anfängt
zu kritzeln das hat bei uns direkt
nebenan also das ist doch jetzt auch gar
nicht schlimm wir haben jetzt eine seite
ich habe auf meinem kanal früher schon
so anderes länder teile gespielt wurde
er auf einmal aus dem keller raus kamen
was soll das denn ich dachte kann sich
nicht bewegen im neuen langsam klick
jetzt drauf und jetzt guckt nicht leicht
nach links um leichte links leicht
langsam langsam langsam ganz langsam
wir haben wir müssen das noch einmal
spielen nur zwei seiten gefunden das
ding ist auch das hat die junge mich
auch gerade gefragt ob die seiten immer
an der gleichen stelle sind da sind die
die sache ist nur dass man nach einer
gewissen zeit einfach keine orientierung
mehr hat und ja nicht weiß okay war ich
hier schon habe ich den baum schon mal
gesehen et cetera pp
du arschloch ich mache das hier gerade
für dich du sollst das eigentlich
spielen
das hier ist dieser kalkstein und hier
dran wird die erste seite sei genau die
haben wir das heißt seit der nummer eins
haben wir genau zu orten
wir versuchen drei seiten die heute noch
zu kriegen nach drei insgesamt machen
wir mal nur wenige minuten später als
aktueller stand sei nach einigen minuten
noch das wir bisher wirklich erst eine
seite haben wir laufen die ganze zeit
durch den wald und wir finden nichts
außer wieder die absperrung wieso läuft
duden immerzu abschauen wieso läuft
jetzt wieder gegen einen baum
als ich einmal ganz langsamen helfen
warum juden in andere richtungen doch
wozu kurzes wort boden zu begehen
meintest du noch was ist denn das für
langweilig gespielt haben dann lauft
doch jetzt müssen wir darum geht einmal
nach vorne stop shop deswegen was tust
du beschreibst du es ist gerade niemand
hier das heißt ich kann jetzt meinen
blick auf den baum lassen und vielleicht
ist ja an dem baum hinterseite jule was
haben wir denn da siehst du das
wollen wir nur noch einen nicht auch
noch eine seite dann bist du hier
entlassen die einfach ein bisschen
weiter geradeaus durch vielleicht sehen
wir wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise wieder
die autos sehen weiss er schon wie die
seite ist da könnt ihr direkt auf allen
drei seiten haben normalerweise muss man
es bei 8 finden um das durchzuspielen
aber drei ist schon nah dran jule ist
jetzt für steuern zuständig und ich
werde das ganze hier selbstverständlich
ein wenig kommentieren wie läuft jetzt
hier auch für bäume zu läuft gegen den
baum
und hier auch nochmal gegen den baum und
den baum nimmt sie auch damit dass ist
dass hoffmann links durch genau genau
darf man hier schon vorbei schauen ob da
irgendwo eine seite ist das heißt du
kannst in die richtung geben genau wie
man das dahin geradeaus durch juli
werden dort die seite findest ohne dass
der sender man uns vorher findet dann
haben wir das spiel quasi beendet
bei uns sorgt genau was ich sehr gut
langsam reißt du denn da ich zitiere
jude von beginn nicht in die richtung
dass der baum dahinter sein genau
langsam satt vans brüssel sollte einfach
weggucken
du liegst du am boden das war's jetzt
hier auf jeden fall vom video meine
damen und herren einem viele haben unter
dem vorderrad mit juni video geschrieben
dass sie mal sehen wollen wie es
aussieht wenn julia ein horrorspiel
spielt ja so sieht es aus wenn wir noch
mal ein anderes spiel spielen sollen
er muss ja kein horror spiel sei dann
schreibt scannen und in die kommentare
lassen like damit es euch gefallen hat
[Musik]